this is how you make crispy mango sticky
rice it's like refreshing dessert nachos
I'll be using four a towel for mangoes
I'm just gonna do rough chop two eggs
now separate the yolks keep the egg
whites we're gonna use this later sugar
and a pinch of salt
heavy cream and milk now we're gonna
bring this to a boil okay once it boils
we're going to add a ladle of the hot
cream this is called tempering the eggs
and add the remaining milk and a good
mix I'm gonna put it back in the same
pan cut the custard gently in low heat
once it hits 185 you should be ready put
the mangoes in the blender then the ice
cream base
in fact if you freeze this sauce it
becomes mango gelato can of coconut milk
and sugar now reduce the coconut milk
until it makes a glaze get a rice paper
sheet brush with the egg whites we saved
earlier and just Place another one on
top
[Applause]
toss it in the coconut milk glaze sesame
seeds now dip it in the mango sauce